So today we're going to talk about Nash
equilibrium. So this is one of the most
important concepts in game theory.
Uh but I want to start by reminding you
a little bit about rationalizability.
Because I think that's going to provide
us a good foundation for talking about
Nash equilibrium seeing how these two
concepts differ.
So as before and throughout this class
we're going to be given a strategic form
game and this notation is going to stay
the same. So we have a strategic form
game. Maybe I'll write strat form
game
which specifies
the set of strategies, the end players,
and then the payoffs that each player
gets as a function of the strategy
profiles that are chosen.
And last time we defined this procedure
to call iterated elimination
of strictly dominated strategies.
And this was a iterative algorithm that
gradually narrowed down or paired down
the strategies that the players had. So
we started with if you remember
the first stage or stage zero, the
initialization stage, was just the set
of all strategies.
All strategy profiles.
And then we went to
this big S S1
S2
and we kept going down until maybe
we had a generic SK
and then at the end we had something
called S infinity.
And it's important to understand maybe
I'll write this up here.
The interpretation of each of these
sets.
So below let me say what is the
interpretation.
The interpretation is that as we're
willing to make stronger and stronger
behavioral assumptions about the way
that the players play, we're able to
make sharper and sharper predictions
about the strategies that we could
observe in practice.
So we start with S0, this
imposed no assumptions.
If we make no assumptions about how
people play, then of course anything is
possible. The set of strategy profiles
that the players may choose is
unrestricted.
But then we move to S1
where there the interpretation is
rationality.
What we said is what if we assume that
every player is rational?
In the sense that every player plays a
best response to some belief about the
opposing player's strategies.
And if we assume that every player is
rational, then we can narrow down our
prediction in the game to the set S1. So
capital S1 is the set of strategy
profiles that are consistent with every
player's rationality.
And just to remember, maybe I'll put it
down here
when I write S capital K, this is really
a product.
Like this.
So S capital K is a set of strategy
profiles that contain a strategy for
player one in this set S1K all the way
up to a strategy for player N in the set
SNK.
And then we could go beyond just
rationality. Remember we went to
S2
and there we assumed not only that the
players are rational, but that the
players know that everyone else is
rational. So we might call this
rationality
plus knowledge of rationality.
I'll just write knowledge of R. So
rationality plus knowledge of
rationality.
But then as we keep going down, we can
get to higher and higher order knowledge
of rationality. So when you get to SK
the interpretation of this is SK is our
prediction in the game if we're willing
to assume rationality
knowledge of rationality
knowledge of others rationality,
knowledge of others knowledge of others
rationality and so on all the way down
to maybe I'll say rationality plus
K minus one order knowledge of
rationality.
Why K minus one? Well, the first stage
we had rationality but no knowledge of
rationality. So the degree of knowledge
of rationality is always just one
smaller than our number K and when we
get up to K this means the players are
rational, they know everyone else is
rational they know that everyone else
knows that they're rational and so on
and those statements go on until I say
the word knows K minus one times.
And then if we want to be really formal,
there's a word for this last set. So
this last set these are the set of
rationalizable strategies.
And the interpretation of this is that
these are the strategy profiles that are
consistent with rationality and
arbitrarily high degrees of knowledge of
rationality. So not only does each
player know everyone else knows they're
rational, but I can continue those
chains arbitrarily deep.
And we have a word for that. That's
called common knowledge of of
rationality.
So I'll write
just write R.
So rationalizable captures the idea that
not only are the players rational, but
they have common knowledge of
rationality in the sense that they have
Kth order knowledge of rationality for
any K. They have first order, second
order, third order, fourth order,
hundredth order and so on.
So this is kind of a summary of
where we go where we've gone so far and
I want you to notice how as we continue
to the right here, we make stronger and
stronger behavioral assumptions and we
get sharper and sharper predictions.
But sometimes even this set S infinity
is not going to give us a very sharp
prediction and we want to go a step
further and that's what Nash equilibrium
is going to do today.
So to motivate that, let's start with
or revisit an example that we've done
before
uh which we called the Boston game
BOS. And remember the story of this game
is we had two friends who like each
other's company but they have different
sports preferences. So they're choosing
whether to go to a Celtics game or Red
Sox game. They're both happier if they
go together than apart, but one person
prefers the Celtics and one person
prefers the Red Sox. So if we
write out the game like this
I think I'll use slightly different
numbers this time to make some of the
math later
a bit easier.
So let's go over it. If we choose
differently, that's along this off
diagonal, then we both get a payoff of
zero. Because we don't get to to be
together at the game.
If we both go to the Celtics game, then
we both get a positive payoff, but it's
higher for player one because player one
likes the Celtics more.
And then conversely, if we both go to
the Red Sox game, we both get a positive
payoff, but here it's the second player
who prefers the Red Sox and therefore
gets the higher payoff of two.
So let's go through our
procedure for calculating best responses
here.
If my opponent is going to the Celtics
game, I certainly want to go to the
Celtics game and if they're going to the
Red Sox game, I want to go to the Red
Sox game.
And then we can do it the other way. Now
put myself in the shoes of player two.
I'm saying if player one plays C, well I
look at my payoffs, I prefer C. If
player one plays R, I look at my
payoffs, I prefer this.
So now
if we look at that, can anyone see what
are the set of rationalizable
strategies or strategy profiles in this
game? So maybe
we'll separate it out just to be clear.
So what are the set of rationalizable
strategies for player one in this game?
Well here it's going to be just C and R.
Right? Because here
if my opponent plays C, I want to play
C.
If my opponent plays R, I want to play
R. So it turns out everything is going
to be rationalizable in this game.
So we're going to get
we go through the procedure
CR
if we go through the procedure
we also get CR
and just to make sure we understand the
notation, S infinity is the set of
rationalizable profiles. So this is
going to have four elements, right? It's
going to have
CC
CR
RC and RR.
Sometimes I'll write these with
parentheses, but it just gets a little
messy here. So this says there's four
strategy profiles. This is the profile
where we both go to the Celtics game.
This is the profile where we both go to
the Red Sox game.
And the order here indicates who does
what. So the first player plays C, the
second player plays R and then
conversely the first player plays R and
the second player plays C.
So in this case everything is
rationalizable. So this is a case where
rationality and common knowledge of
rationality alone doesn't give us a very
good prediction or doesn't rule out many
possibilities. So we're not able to get
a very sharp prediction. And let's see.
So in particular, one rationalizable
strategy profile I should say is this.
So this is rationalizable
but it may seem like something is going
wrong here.
So does this seem like a reasonable
prediction of how people are playing or
would you say someone's making a mistake
here?
What seems strange about this when
player one is going to the Red Sox
and player two is going to the Celtics
game?
Yeah.
They're both losing, right? And in a
sense, well
I'm going to the Red Sox game, but if I
just changed my behavior and went to the
Celtics game, I'd be better off. And
similarly, the other person who's alone
at the Celtics game, if they move to the
Red Sox game, they'd be better off,
right?
So,
there's a bit of this incongruity that
we say, "Okay, this is consistent with
rationality and common knowledge of
rationality, but it might feel somehow
that the players are making a mistake."
So,
so maybe I'll say this is all a bit
informal, it feels like a mistake.
And let's try to reconcile this. Why
does this satisfy the definition of
rationalizability, but feel like a
mistake? And I think the best way to
think about that is, what does
rationalizability really mean?
It really means that a player has an
explanation for why they're doing what
they're doing.
So, I think rationalizability should be
thought of
as it means that a player has an
explanation.
So, what is player one's explanation for
why they're going to the Red Sox game?
They would say, "Well, it's reasonable,
it's rational for me to go to the Red
Sox game because I believe
that my my friend is also going to the
Red Sox game."
And then we can go a step deeper. We
could say,
"Well, why do you believe that your
friend is going to the Red Sox game?"
And you could say, "Well, I believe my
friend is going to the Red Sox game
because I believe that my friend
believes that I'm going to the Red Sox
game."
Then you go a step deeper, you can say,
"Why do you believe that your friend
believes that you're going to the Red
Sox game?" Well, I think my friend
believes that I believe that my friend
believes
he's going to the Red Sox game, and that
explains his belief, and we can go on
and on and on. And that's precisely what
rationalizability captures. It says you
can provide an explanation that goes
arbitrarily deep. So, think of this as
the answer to the child who always says,
"But why this?" Right? You can always go
a step deeper. Why do they have this
belief? Well, they have this belief
because of this other belief, and that
chain never stops.
If it weren't rationalizable, eventually
we'd reach a problem, we'd reach a
contradiction in that chain.
So, rationalizability says there exists
some explanation for your play. The
problem is your explanation may not be
correct. In theory, it's a good
explanation, but it might not actually
comport with the way that people are
playing.
So, rationalizability means you have an
explanation, you're behaving optimally
given this explanation or given these
beliefs, but there's no requirement that
the explanation is correct.
That your beliefs
or your explanation, I'll use these kind
of
This explanation is a bit deeper.
Because if we're down here, my
explanation involved my belief
that my
friend was also going to the Red Sox
game.
But in fact, my friend is not doing
that. My friend is going to the Celtics
game, and that's why I'm doing badly.
So, what Nash equilibrium is going to
capture is it's going to go a step
beyond simply providing an explanation.
It's going to require that the
explanations we provide are also
correct. That is, they also accurately
describe the way that our opponents or
that our fellow players are actually
playing.
So, let's now give the formal definition
of this.
So, this is, you know, if you learn one
thing about game theory, this is often,
you know, the definition you see.
In the movie about Nash, they talk about
this, though actually their story is
kind of wrong in the movie, it doesn't
make uh
mathematical sense, but anyway, um okay,
so, a strategy profile
Let me just stop here and say I think
this is really an important aspect of
the definition. That the thing that
we're the thing that a Nash equilibrium
will be is a strategy profile. And often
a mistake students make on exams is
they're asked to give an equilibrium,
and they often don't give a strategy
profile. They might give the payoffs
that the players get if they use that
strategy profile. But an equilibrium is
always a strategy profile because it's a
prediction or recommendation for the how
people will play in the game. So, this
is the key first part. It's a profile
specifying a strategy for the first
player all the way up to a strategy for
the nth player.
So, this kind of strategy profile is
a Nash equilibrium
So, this is named after
John Nash,
uh who won the Nobel Prize in economics.
He wrote this paper in '48, '49. He
wrote a few papers that introduced this
concept. It's actually interesting to
read the original paper. The original
paper is like two paragraphs long, uh
and he got the Nobel Prize for it. So,
if you have good ideas, it doesn't You
don't need to go on and on and on. So,
uh a strategy profile is a Nash
equilibrium if
for
each or every player I,
the following holds.
So, I'm going to put myself in the
position of player I,
and I'm going to compare the payoff I
get from my strategy to the payoff I
could get if I deviated to a different
strategy.
So, I'm going to compare
UI of SI star on the left
to UI of SI prime on the right.
So, I'm comparing I'm player I,
and I'm saying, "If I choose SI star,
what I'm supposed to do in equilibrium,
I want to do better weekly than if I
choose some other strategy SI prime."
But I still have to fill this in, right?
And this is going to say, "Given the way
that the other players are playing." So,
what I'm going to fill in here is S
negative I star
and S negative I star.
I can't control how the other people are
playing. So, I take that as fixed, I
take that as given.
Given the way that my opponents are
playing,
I just do what I can control. I compare
the strategy I'm supposed to choose
to any deviation, and I require that the
strategy I'm supposed to choose is
weekly better
for all
SI prime
in SI.
In particular, SI prime could just be
SI star,
but then this is going to be satisfied
automatically cuz both sides are going
to be the same.
So, let's think of another way to say
this.
Another way to say this, so this is
equivalent to this statement here,
is that SI star
is a best response
to S negative I star.
So, another way of defining a Nash
equilibrium is to say that every player
I look at, if I look at the strategy
that player is using,
that strategy better be a best response
to the strategies that the other players
are using.
Now, we have to be a bit careful here
because when we first defined a best
response,
we defined a best response to a belief,
not to a strategy of the opponents,
right? But when I say a best response to
the strategy profile, what I really
mean, if I want to be really formal, is
I mean to the belief that assigns
probability one to my opponents playing
this strategy profile. So, to
more formally, the belief
beta negative I
with beta negative I of S negative I
star
equal one.
So, if my belief is my opponents are
certain
to play S negative I star, then the best
thing for me to do, or a best thing for
me to do, is to play SI star.
And here you can immediately see in the
definition the consistency that we're
imposing on beliefs. So, I think keeping
in keeping in mind this interpretation
is crucial cuz when you first see the
definition, you might say, "Where are
the beliefs?"
Well, because we're requiring
consistency of beliefs, the beliefs are
the same as what's actually happening.
So, S negative I star is how the other
players are actually playing,
and beta negative I is my correct belief
that the players are playing exactly how
they are playing. So, sometimes we can
lose track of this distinction between
play and beliefs because our definition
requires that they agree.
Maybe we can give a bit of a less
mathematical
frame
uh on this. So, another way we might say
it is we might say that no player
has a strictly profitable
unilateral deviation.
So, let's kind of break down what this
means.
No players, let's focus on a single
player,
should have a strictly profitable
unilateral deviation.
So, a deviation for a player is a
strategy that's that deviates from or is
different from
their conjectured equilibrium strategy.
So, we start with SI star for player I,
and we contemplate an alternative
strategy for player I.
A unilateral deviation means I'm the
only one who's changing my strategy.
And this is, I think, the key, maybe the
most important idea that Nash introduced
was that when I'm reasoning about other
people,
I should take their behavior and their
strategies as fixed because I can't
directly control what they do. So, when
I contemplate deviating, I only consider
a change in my strategy.
And you can see that up here in this
inequality that the way that my
opponents are playing is the same on
both sides of the inequality.
The only difference between the two
sides is how I'm playing as player I.
And we this strategy cannot be this
deviation cannot be strictly profitable.
It could be that you have a deviation
that gives you the same payoff
as your equilibrium strategy, but it
can't be that you can deviate and do
strictly better.
And again, we're using profitability not
in the sense of a monetary payoff, but
in the sense of utilities. So, a
profitable deviation is a deviation that
gives me a higher utility, a strictly
higher expected utility.
So, let's go back to this game
and see if we can find the
Nash equilibria of this game. Any
guesses on what the Nash equilibria of
this BOS game are going to be based on
the definition? Or based on the things
we've written, yeah?
Right. So, these are going to be the two
Nash equilibria.
How can we see this? Well, let's suppose
we're both going to the Celtics game.
Does anyone have a profitable unilateral
deviation?
No, because if I were to unilaterally
deviate, we're together at the Celtics
game. If I deviate, I'm by myself at the
other game, so I'm certainly worse off.
And the same is true if we go to the Red
Sox game. If we're both going to the Red
Sox game, if I unilaterally deviate, I'm
going to be worse off.
Now,
of course, if we're both going to the
Red Sox game and I'm player one,
I would much rather that we both go to
the Celtics game
because I'm a Celtics fan.
But moving from here to here is not a
unilateral deviation. All I can control
is whether I go to the Red Sox game or
the Celtics game. Of course, I would
love to force you to come to the Celtics
game with me, but that's not something I
can do in this game.
So, that's the intuitive explanation.
Mathematically, we can see that both
numbers are underlined.
And that's actually a great way to
compute Nash equilibria in games like
this. So, we we go through for player
one, we underline all of their best
responses,
then we go through player two and
underline all of their best responses,
and we look, so I guess this is kind of
an algorithm for finding them.
So, step one
is underlining best responses.
And it's crucial that you underline both
players' best responses and you
underline all best responses.
So, let me say
all best responses
for both players.
And then step two is you just check
which cells or which boxes in the matrix
have both numbers underlined.
So,
look for cells.
What is a cell? Well, a cell in this
context is just a strategy profile. So,
let's remember that.
And if you
think through this carefully, you'll see
this is just an another way of saying
the definition. If both cells are
underlined, well, if the first player's
number is underlined, that precisely
means player one is playing a best
response to player two's strategy.
And if player two's number is
underlined, that means player two is
playing a best response to player one's
strategy. And that's exactly our
definition of a Nash equilibrium, at
least in a two-player game.
So, this is a good way of going through
and finding and checking for Nash
equilibrium.
Okay. So, now I think it's helpful to
try to understand
the relationship between
some of the
solution concepts and some of the
definitions we've given so far.
So, so far we have kind of three,
I think, important definitions.
One was rationalizability.
And we represented the set of
rationalizable strategy profiles, we
called that S infinity.
Then another important notion is Nash
equilibrium.
And let's call this NE. So, let me think
of NE as the set of Nash equilibrium
strategy profiles in a game.
So, just to be clear, this is a subset
of S, right?
What kind of objects are these? These
are strategy profiles. So,
rationalizable strategy profiles live in
the set of all strategy profiles.
Then the set of Nash equilibria, that's
also a subset of big S because a Nash
equilibrium is also a strategy profile.
And then we had another notion,
remember, which was dominant strategy
equilibrium.
And we'll call that DSE,
and that's also
a subset of S.
So, we have sort of three sets of
strategy profiles here. Let's remember a
dominant strategy equilibrium, if you
recall from the dominance lecture, was a
strategy profile where each player's
strategy is a weakly dominant strategy.
That was the definition.
So, now what we'd like to understand is
the relationship between them.
If something's a dominant strategy
equilibrium, is it a Nash equilibrium?
If it's rationalizable, is it a Nash
equilibrium? And so on.
I think a good way to get started when
you're approaching a question like this
is to work through an example and see if
you can get some inspiration from that.
So, let's look at our BOS example. So,
here, the set of rationalizable
strategies
was all four strategies, right?
The set of Nash equilibria in this game
over here were just two strategy
profiles, right? CC and RR.
What about the set of dominant strategy
equilibria? Which profiles were dominant
strategy equilibria
in this game?
Any thoughts?
Well, let's go through for player one.
Let's check. Is C a dominant strategy
for player one? That is, does C always
do better than R and sometimes do
strictly better?
Well, no, because if the other player
plays R,
then C does worse than R. C gives me
zero and R gives me one. So, C does not
weakly dominate R.
And now let's ask the other question.
Does R weakly dominate C?
Well, no, because if my opponent goes to
the Celtics game, I'd rather go to the
Celtics game than go to the Red Sox
game.
So, neither does C dominate R,
nor does R dominate C.
And that means that neither of them is
weakly dominant cuz if it was weakly
dominant, it would have to weakly
dominate everything else.
And therefore, we have no dominant
strategy equilibria in this game.
So, here we have
none.
Or you might say we have the empty set.
So, at least in this example, we see
that Nash equilibrium is more demanding
than rationalizability. The Nash
equilibria are a subset of the
rationalizable strategy profiles.
And dominant strategy equilibrium is
even more demanding still.
Every You know, it's a bit weird to say
it in this case cuz there are none of
them, but it's vacuously true that every
dominant strategy equilibrium is a Nash
equilibrium. There just aren't any of
them. But if there were one, it would be
a Nash equilibrium. So, that gives us
maybe a conjecture based on this example
about the relationship between them. And
you know, I chose the example so we
wouldn't be led astray, and indeed, this
is a a result that in general,
we have DSE
subset
of NE subset of S infinity, and maybe
I'll write subset of S just to remind us
kind of the space that we're in over
here. Right?
So, let's understand what these subset
relationships mean.
DSE is a set. It's the set of all
dominant strategy equilibria, which is a
set of strategy profiles.
This is another set, and this is another
set.
So, this inclusion tells me
every dominant strategy equilibrium
is necessarily a Nash equilibrium.
The converse isn't necessarily true.
It could be that something's a Nash
equilibrium, but not a dominant strategy
equilibrium.
Can you come up with an example of a
Nash equilibrium that's not a dominant
strategy equilibrium, maybe in this
game?
Yeah? Like CC is a Nash equilibrium, but
it's not a dominant strategy
equilibrium.
Right. And same with RR. So, here it's
kind of easy because there are no
dominant strategy equilibria. So, both
of the Nash equilibria are examples of
Nash equilibria that are not dominant
strategy equilibria.
And then similarly,
we have there are some rationalizable
strategy profiles that are not Nash
equilibria. In this example,
CR and RC are two profiles that are
rationalizable, but not uh Nash
equilibria.
Now, sometimes these sets could agree,
but sometimes this set could be strictly
bigger. But our claim here is just that
everything in here is in here, and
everything in here isn't here. And now
we'd like to kind of go through the
reasoning for that. But are there any
questions on what I mean by the
statement before we go through the
argument?
Okay.
Okay. So, let's try to think through it.
So,
here's the argument.
Let's There's two different things we
want to show. I mean, let's be clear.
This This is just for context. This
relationship is obvious. It's just by
definition. Every rationalizable
strategy profile is a strategy profile.
So, we have two things to check.
So, let's do the first one. The first
one is that DSE
is a subset of NE.
So, that's kind of a mathy way of saying
it, but what we mean is if you give me a
dominant strategy equilibrium of some
game,
I know that it must be a Nash
equilibrium of that game.
So, let's see how we can show that. So,
first, let's start with a dominant
strategy equilibrium. So, suppose
S star, which I'll write S1 star
up to SN star,
is a DSE.
That's your starting point. We're just
going to
take a strategy profile and make the
assumption that it is a dominant
strategy
equilibrium,
and we want to now reason through why
this strategy profile must also be a
Nash equilibrium.
Well,
to show that it's a Nash equilibrium, we
have to check that no player
has a profitable unilateral deviation.
So, let's
take consider a player.
So, that means that
for each player I
let's consider player I and let's also
consider a potential deviation by player
I.
So, for each player I
and each strategy
SI prime
what do we want to show?
We want to show that this deviation is
not profitable for player I.
That is we want to show that for player
I
it's better for them to play SI star
than to play SI prime
given the way that their opponents are
playing.
Right?
But, that's what we want to show.
All we know is that this is a dominant
strategy equilibrium. So, what's
something useful?
Do you have any ideas of how we could
kind of use the fact that we this is a
dominant strategy equilibrium to get us
started? What do we know about SI star?
Given that S star is a dominant strategy
equilibrium.
Yeah.
SI star will be dominant.
SI Yeah, so let's let's go through it in
turn. Because it's a dominant strategy
equilibrium, we know that SI star is
weakly dominant.
And what does it mean to be weakly
dominant? It means that SI star weakly
dominates every other strategy of player
I.
But, in particular, that means SI star
weakly dominates SI prime cuz that's
another strategy of player I.
So, we know that SI star
weakly dominates
SI prime.
We know more than that, but we here
we're just throwing away information. If
SI star weakly dominates everything, in
particular
it weakly dominates SI prime.
And now can we reach the conclusion we
want?
Well, yeah, if SI star weakly dominates
SI prime
that means SI star always does weakly
better than SI prime no matter how my
opponents are playing.
So, if that's true and sometimes
strictly better.
So, if that's true no matter how my
opponents are playing, it's certainly
true in the particular way my opponents
are playing now.
So, that tells me
that UI of SI star
SI negative S negative I star is greater
than equal to UI
SI prime
So, because SI star weakly dominates SI
prime, this inequality would be true
whatever I put on both sides here. I
could put any as long as I put the same
thing on both sides. So, in particular,
if I put the way my opponents are
actually playing, this is going to be
true.
And this precisely means that
SI star
is a best response
to S negative I star.
So, I conclude
SI star
is a best response
to S negative I star.
Well I reason for player I, but I can go
through the exact same argument for all
the other players.
So, not only is player I playing a best
response to the way everyone else is
playing but every single player I is
playing a best response to the way
everyone else is playing.
So, I'll say therefore
S star is a Nash equilibrium.
So, if you're not so familiar with
writing proofs, this kind of reasoning
may be
a little tricky. Let me pause. Do you
have any questions on this?
So, it's really just about being
organized and going step by step. I
don't think none of the steps is too
difficult, but you kind of have to keep
in mind where you're going, where you're
starting and uh kind of carefully go
through the logic of it.
But, the basic idea is pretty simple. If
what I'm doing is better is best no
matter how my opponents play, it's
certainly best given the particular way
that my opponents are playing. And
that's the high-level idea of this.
Okay. So, now let's try to show the
second part. So, I have shown that every
dominant strategy equilibrium is a Nash
equilibrium. Notice, I didn't show that
there exists a dominant strategy
equilibrium. My starting point here was
let's take something that's a dominant
strategy equilibrium. Maybe there's no
dominant strategy equilibrium. That's
okay. But, I'm saying if there is one
it must also be a Nash equilibrium.
And now let's go
see if we can do this next step.
So, part two is to show that every Nash
equilibrium
is rationalizable.
So, if I start with something that's a
Nash equilibrium, it better be a
rationalizable strategy profile.
Now, this seems a bit hard
because the way we defined S infinity
was really tricky, right? We went
through this whole iterative procedure.
We had an algorithm. We had to go
through infinitely many steps.
So, are there any Do you have any ideas
about how we might
show this?
Any mathematical technique that might be
useful
for this kind of proof?
Yeah? Proof by contradiction.
Uh we could I I think a proof by
contradiction would work. Yeah, I saw
but I saw another hand. Yeah? Induction.
Induction is a good idea. A
contradiction would work.
A lot of things you could convert it,
but I think induction is a really
natural idea because we've defined S
infinity inductively.
So, we'd like to use induction and if
you haven't heard of induction, that's
okay. I'll go through it.
Um
Okay, but let's first just understand
what we're trying to do.
We're going to follow the same procedure
as before. So, suppose
S star
this is a strategy profile
is a Nash equilibrium.
What do we want to do? We want to show
that S star is rationalizable. Right?
So
we want to show
that S star
is in S infinity.
But, doing that directly is kind of hard
because S infinity is only the result of
this iterative procedure.
But, remember from over here
the way we got to S infinity is we just
kept kept making the set smaller and
smaller and smaller.
So, one way or what's equivalent to
showing that S star is in S infinity
so I'll say or equivalently
and easier to show
S star
is in SK
for all K.
Right? So, let's just say this in words.
We want to show that S star survives
every round of elimination and makes it
till the end.
Well, the way we show that is we just
show it makes it to the first step and
the second step and the third step and
the fourth step and the fifth step and
it never gets thrown out and therefore
it must survive all the way to the end.
So, we want to show that this strategy
profile must survive every round of
elimination.
And since we're showing something for
every K, this is where we're going to
use induction. So, what do we want to
show? We want to show that first So,
let's there's a base case
of K equals zero. We want to show first
that S star is in there after the zeroth
round.
And then we have an inductive step that
says if it's made it to the Kth round,
it's also going to make it to the K plus
first round.
And then we can just tie it all
together, right? If we know it makes it
to the zeroth round then it must make it
to the first. If it makes it to the
first, it must make it to the second and
so on and we can just chain our
reasoning together.
So, for the base case of K equals zero
what we need to show
is that S star
is in
S zero.
And maybe I'll put a question mark
because this is not a claim. This is I'm
not saying it's true. It's what we're
trying to show. So, is S star in S zero?
Well, yeah, because S zero is just a set
of all strategy profiles.
Right? And S star is a strategy profile.
So, that's
that's pretty easy.
This is just by definition.
The heart of the proof is the inductive
step, right?
So, here's the inductive step.
What we want to show is in general is if
S star makes it through the first K
rounds then it must make it one more
round. It must also make it to the K
plus first round.
So, what we want to show and maybe I'll
say WTS cuz it's always important in
proofs to be clear about what you're
assuming and what you're trying to show.
So, WTS
is just an abbreviation for want to
show. What I want to show is that
if S star
is in SK
then
S star
is in SK plus one.
So, if I haven't thrown it out by the
Kth round
I'm not going to throw it out at the K
plus first round.
I think if we just look at it like this,
it can be a little tricky because
remember the way we defined this
procedure was we had to reason kind of
player by player. So, let's write that
more explicitly.
What does it mean for this strategy
profile to be in SK?
It means the Ith component of that
profile, player I's strategy, is in SI K
for each of the players I. And I think
that's a bit
more concrete. So, that means that SI
star
that is remember S star is a profile of
strategies. SI star is the strategy that
player I is actually using, that must be
in
SI K
and this is true for all I.
And now symmetrically, what we're trying
to show
is that
SI star
is in SI K plus one
for all I.
Now, I think it's
we often when we go through proofs and
arguments, we only go through the the
right way of doing it, and I think you
can sometimes lose sight of
uh how hard it is cuz you
uh you kind of don't show all the wrong
paths. And there's an easy mistake
people make here. What's really tempting
at this point is to say, "Okay, let me
reason player by player."
So, I want to look at player I,
and I want to say, "If player I's
strategy has survived up to round K,
then player I's strategy should survive
up to round K + 1."
That's not going to get you very far.
And the reason is that
which strategies for player I survive up
to round K + 1 depend on which
strategies of player I's opponents have
survived up to round K.
Because when I'm choosing when we go
through the algorithm, what's the best
response for player I, it depends on
what strategies of my opponents have
survived so far. So, we really have to
reason simultaneously about all the
players. We can't just reason through it
separately because which strategies
survive for player I depend on which
strategies of the other players have
survived so far.
So, let's try to
go through this argument.
Okay, so here's the the argument.
So, let's consider player I.
So, we know that SI star is in SIK. But
I've argued that that's actually not so
useful for us.
What's more important from the
perspective of player I?
What do I care about when I as I'm
player I? I care about what strategies
my opponents might play, right? So, the
important thing in is that we know
that
S negative I star
is in S negative I K.
This is the key the key part of our So,
our inductive assumption is that
everyone's strategy has survived so far,
but the relevant aspect of that
assumption is the fact that all of my
opponent's strategies have survived so
far because that's what's going to
determine what strategies are best
responses for me.
So, this is what we know.
Okay.
And
what we want to show
is that
SI star
is in SI
K + 1, right? So, this is what we know.
This is what we want to show. I think
this is often a good way to try to get
through proofs.
So, I think the first thing we should do
is just write down some definitions,
right? What is SI K + 1?
What is the definition of SI K + 1?
Uh yeah, over here.
In the uh
Boston sweatshirt, yeah.
It's like the all um
it's the set of strategies that are
um best responses to uh
something in S
I K. Exactly right. And we have notation
for that. That's exactly what it is in
words. And in math, we'll just convert
that into math is S negative I K.
Right?
So, what is which strategies survive up
to the K plus first round? It's all the
strategies for player I
that are best responses for player I
to
some belief over the strategies in S
negative I K. So, these are the
strategies I consider possible that my
opponents might play, and I want to
think about all best responses to that.
So, now we just have to put things
together.
We know that S negative I star is in S
negative I K.
We want to show that SI star is a best
response to something in S neg- negative
I K.
What's the What's the key step? What do
we
What's the leap here? So, why is this
true?
Yeah. So, SI star is by definition a
best response to S negative I star, and
that's what you just showed is going to
be in S I K.
Exactly right. So, by the definition of
Nash equilibrium, let me explain this.
By the definition of Nash equilibrium,
we know that SI star is a best response
to S negative I star, right?
So, let's And remember, this is a small
S. This is a big S. This is a small S,
right? So, we know that SI star is a
best response to S negative I star.
And we've know by our inductive
hypothesis that S negative I star is a
strategy in S negative I K.
So, it just follows by definition that
therefore S negative I star is a best
response to some belief about things in
S negative I K. Specifically, it's a
best response to the belief that puts
all the probability on this strategy.
So, we're done.
We've shown that SI star is in SI K + 1,
and if we reason exactly the same way
for all the players, we'll show that
this holds for every single player I,
and now we've completed our inductive
step.
But so again, I think each individual
step is not too hard, but piecing it
together and kind of thinking through
this is a bit tricky. So again, are
there any questions on
this argument?
So, now let's uh
go a little farther. Let's go to another
example.
This is another classic game, and this
is called sometimes hide and seek.
So, think of this as, you know, the
childhood game. Someone hides, the other
person seeks, and the hider doesn't want
to get caught, and the seeker does want
to catch the other person.
Of course, there's more substantive
examples. You might think of someone
cheating on their taxes trying to hide,
and then the IRS seeking trying to
figure out which line of their taxes
they cheated on. So, I think it has
broader implications, but we'll keep
with the hide and seek story. So, let's
say player one is the hider, and there's
two places they can hide.
And player two is the seeker, and
there's two places they can look for the
person.
So, the seeker is going to win
if they look where the person hid,
right?
So, that means we're going to have
Give myself a little more space.
-1 1
-1 1 because here
person one hid in spot A,
person two looked for them in spot A.
That means person one gets caught, so
they get a payoff of -1, and the other
player gets a payoff of one.
And the same is true if they both
hide and seek in spot B.
But then over here, we're going to have
the opposite.
So, here, if I as player one hide in
spot B,
and player two looks for me in A, then
they're not going to find me,
and therefore I get a payoff of one, and
the other player gets a payoff of -1.
You could also think of the hider as the
penalty taker, and the seeker as the
goalie. Um there's a lot of different
stories you could tell.
Um
So, notice the difference between this
game and the game we discussed before.
So,
this is a game of pure conflict of
interest.
In the Boston game, there was there was
there were both. There was some conflict
of interest because one person liked the
Red Sox, and one person liked the
Celtics, but there was also some common
interest because they both liked each
other's company, and they wanted to be
together.
Here, it's purely a conflict of
interest. I want us as player one, I
want us to hide in different places.
So, maybe I'll say that. So, what does
player one want?
They want them to look and hide in
different places,
maybe different locations.
And player two
wants them to be in the same location.
Of course, the hard part is you can only
choose your location. If you could
choose the other person's location, then
it would be it would be easy.
So, as a first step for this, let's go
through our standard procedure where we
compute player one's best responses to
player two, and player two's best
responses to player one.
So, let's do it slowly. If I'm player
one,
if player two guesses A, then I want to
hide, so I want to do B.
And if player two guesses B, I want to
hide and be in a different place, so I
would like to be A.
Now, let's look at the other way. Now,
let's look at the perspective of player
two.
If player one plays A, then player two
does better if they also go A cuz they
want to find the person.
And if player one goes B, then player
two
wants to go B.
So, this is So, we've computed the best
responses.
We can look, and if we
follow our algorithm, where are the Nash
equilibria in this game?
We want to look for a cell where both
numbers are underlined, right? But here
we have a problem because none of the
cells are underlined.
So, what this tells us is that this game
has no and this will be important in a
second pure strategy Nash equilibrium.
And we can kind of think through it
reasonably, right?
If
in order for us to have an a Nash
equilibrium, neither player can have a
profitable deviation.
But if we're in the same place,
then someone certainly has a profitable
deviation, right? The hider would rather
deviate if we're in the same place.
And if we're in different places, then
again, someone would like to deviate.
The seeker would like to deviate and
change places so that so that they find
the person who's hiding.
So, because of this immense conflict of
interest, we can't have a pure strategy
Nash equilibrium because someone's
losing
and whoever's losing would rather change
their behavior so that they could win.
This is a a zero-sum game in the in a
formal sense that we'll talk about more
later.
But we'd still like to make a prediction
about playing this game. If we just use
rationalizability, well, anything could
happen because I can hide in A if I
think the other person's going to B and
I can hide in B if I think they're going
to A and we can explain everything.
So, I don't know, how would you play
this game and if if you were
taking penalty kicks in the World Cup,
how would you what strategy would you
use?
Yeah? Mixed strategy. You'd use a mixed
strategy, right? So, you you'd randomize
and in this case, how do you think you
would
randomize?
Would you play A 99% of the time?
Half and half. Probably half and half,
right? Because you don't want yourself
to be predictable, right? And this is
that if you look at the data on World
Cup penalty takers, that's a pretty good
prediction, right? They
I mean, okay, sometimes right-footed
players have a bit of a left advantage
and there's all these subtleties, but
roughly uh people mix 50/50 because if I
develop a reputation, if everyone knows
that I, you know, if you think about
playing hide-and-seek with a young kid,
sometimes they just always hide in the
same place. It's pretty easy to beat
them, right? Um so, and even if you
don't always hide in the same place, if
you hide in the same place 95% of the
time, you'd also be pretty easy to find.
So, it seems pretty intuitive that you'd
want to do half half. So, that's a good
guess and that's right. So, it turns out
it will have a mixed strategy Nash
equilibrium.
So, but
half half
meaning player one randomizes half half
between A and B. Let me write this a bit
more explicitly.
Half A plus half B,
{half A
plus half B}.
This means player one mixes 50/50
and player two mixes 50/50. This is
going to be a Nash equilibrium in mixed
strategies.
So, I'd say this is
maybe I'll use the acronym mixed
strategy NE, MSNE, mixed strategy Nash
equilibrium.
But I haven't even defined what that is,
so let's now define that. I think it's
exactly what you'd think.
So, definition,
a mixed strategy profile
and now we'll use sigma instead of S to
remind us that this is mixed, so sigma
star
equals sigma one star
sigma n star
is a Nash equilibrium
and we'll give exactly the same
definition if for each player I
What happens? Well,
I'm comparing now
>> [snorts]
>> what I'm supposed to do as player I to a
deviation
which I'll maybe call sigma I prime.
So, this is the mixed strategy I'm
actually playing.
This is the mixed strategy I could
deviate to
and I want this to be optimal given the
way my opponents are playing.
So, this is some new notation. We've
been using capital SI to denote all the
pure strategies of player I.
It's often convenient to use
this, it's like the summation symbol and
this is capital sigma and this is the
set of all mixed strategies by player I.
So, we use lowercase s for pure
strategy, uppercase S for a set of pure
strategies,
lowercase sigma for a mixed strategy and
uppercase sigma for a set of mixed
strategies.
So, it's the same idea, given the way my
opponents are playing,
my strategy is a best response. My mixed
strategy does weakly better than any
other mixed strategy I could use.
But if you look at this definition, it
it's a pretty messy because
there's so many different mixed
strategies I could deviate to.
Right? Even in a game with just two
strategies, I could deviate to any
probability between zero and one. That's
a lot of deviations to deal with.
But fortunately, we don't actually have
to worry about that. So, it turns out
even if I were to check every mixed
strategy, it's actually enough just to
check my pure strategy deviations.
So, it turns out this is the same as
the same thing, but with SI prime
for all SI prime.
So, when I use the two dashes, I'm just
saying every everything else in the
definition is the same, but instead of
saying it must do better than any mixed
strategy, I'm saying it must be do
weakly better than any pure strategy.
And we could give a formal math proof,
but let's just think of the intuition,
right?
If I I'd rather do what I'm doing than
deviate to any pure strategy,
then by choosing to flip a coin and mix
over those pure strategies, I can't do
strictly better, right? Because if I mix
over those pure strategies, my payoff is
just going to be an average of my payoff
from all the pure deviations. So, if
each of the pure deviations makes me
weakly worse off, then a mixture of them
must also make me weakly worse off.
That's the intuition. You could write
down a formal mathematical proof, but
the point is it's really important here
that what I am doing can be mixed. So, I
want people to really understand this.
This is crucial.
It's crucial that we're allowing my
equilibrium strategy to be mixed and not
pure.
But when I contemplate the deviations,
it's enough to only look at pure
strategies. And that's a key uh a key
difference here. So, indeed, how can we
tell that mixtures matter? Well, already
in this game here, we saw that it didn't
have a pure strategy Nash equilibrium,
but it does have a mixed strategy Nash
equilibrium. So, the fact that we allow
the equilibrium strategy to be mixed is
is essential.
But when you're contemplating
deviations, you only have to worry about
pure strategies.
And let's take that randomization idea a
little further, right? Why would I ever
want to play a mixed strategy? I mean,
why am I willing to flip a coin and
sometimes get go to A and sometimes go
to B?
I mean, if A is better, wouldn't I just
always want to go to A? And if B is
better, wouldn't I just always want to
go to B? Why would I ever want to flip a
coin or why would I ever be willing to
flip a coin and play A with some of the
time and B some of the time?
What must be true?
If I'm Yeah? A is better in some
circumstances and B is
better.
Okay, that's true, but what about given
my belief, given the way my opponents
are playing, what must be true?
If I strictly preferred A to B given the
way my opponents were playing, would I
want to mix between A and B?
No. Yeah? Does your opponent also have
to be playing a mixed strategy?
So, that
that's related, but maybe not quite
where we are. So, if I'm willing to mix
between A and B, it must be that I'm
indifferent between A and B.
That's the key thing, right? If I
strictly preferred A to B,
I would never play B with positive
probability at all.
And if I strictly preferred B, I would
never play A with positive probability.
So, I'm only willing to flip a coin
and sometimes play A and sometimes play
B if I'm exactly indifferent between A
and B. Now, this gets to your point, why
will I be indifferent between A and B?
It'll be precisely because my opponent
is mixing, right?
So, this is a key observation.
Maybe I'll start a new board.
So, this is
key observation.
So, mixing is optimal
only if you're indifferent between the
things you're mixing over.
And in fact, we can say something even
stronger.
It's not just enough that I'm
indifferent, but I'm only willing to mix
over pure strategies that are best
responses.
So, it must be
um and in fact,
it's only optimal to mix
over pure best responses.
So, what does that mean? Well, I just
sort of a silly example, right? What if
I had A, B, and C?
Okay? And given the way my opponents
were playing, A gave me one, B gave me
one, and C gave me two.
Right? Do I want to mix over A and B?
Well, no, even though I'm indifferent
between A and B, that's necessary, but
it's not sufficient. I certainly don't
want to mix over A and B because C is
strictly better. So, if I'm willing to
mix, I must be indifferent, but
sometimes people get confused and they
get it backwards and they say, if I'm
indifferent, I must be willing to mix.
But no, it's not just enough to be
indifferent, it also has to be optimal
what you're mixing over. And that's
precisely what I'm saying here. It's
only optimal to mix over pure best
responses. So, if I added D at two, now
indeed, I'd be willing to mix between C
and D.
Okay? So, now let's try to check
going back to this game
that half half is actually
a Nash equilibrium, right?
So, So think the best way to do it is to
say well, let's take the perspective of
player two.
And let's suppose that player one mixes
half half.
Okay?
What payoff does player two get from
playing A and playing B?
So what I'm going to imagine is I'm
going to add a new strategy here.
Half A half B.
So I'm adding a new row to this matrix
that's going to represent the payoffs if
player one chooses this mixed strategy.
So in here what I want to write is what
are the expected payoffs
if player one uses this mixed strategy
and player two plays B. Sorry, plays A.
And then over here, what am I going to
write? I'm going to write the payoffs if
player one plays this mixed strategy and
player two plays B.
Okay?
And it turns out this kind of a well,
let's let's go through it.
If I play if player two plays A
and player one plays A with probability
half and B with probability half
then what is the payoff of
what are the payoffs going to be for the
players?
Well, player one is going to get -1 with
probability of half
and one with probability half
which just gives them zero.
And player two is also going to get one
with probability half and -1 with
probability half, so we just get zero.
And if we go to this side, we're
actually just going to get zeros again.
And mathematically, the way we form this
row of the matrix is we just take this
row, multiply it by half
take this row, multiply it by half and
add them together. And when we do that,
we exactly get 0 0 0 0.
So in particular, the key thing about
this
is that these numbers are the same.
So what this tells me
is
if player one
plays half A plus half B
then player two gets a payoff of zero if
they play A
and a payoff of zero if they play B.
And that means that player two is
indifferent between A and B and in fact
A and B are both pure best responses. So
if I'm indifferent between A and B, then
I'm also willing to mix over A and B and
therefore
it's a best response for player two to
mix half half.
So technically what I've shown is
if player one is mixing half half it's a
best response for player two to mix half
half.
So technically if I want to finish the
argument, I need to show the other
direction that if player two mixes half
half, then it's a best response for
player one to mix half half, but it's
going to be entirely symmetric. I could
add another column here and go 0 0, but
we can check that
um
I'll just put a check mark. We checked
it's an equilibrium. Don't do that in
your homework, but that's all we need.
Now let's do return to the Boston game.
Don't know if we have it. I may have to
write it again.
You can write it again. It's okay.
So now let's go to the BOS game. This is
a bit trickier.
And we have Celtics Red Sox Celtics Red
Sox
2 1 1 2
0 0 0 0.
So this game, we already found some pure
equilibria. We found two of them. We
said there's one equilibrium where we
both play C
and there's one equilibrium where we
both play R.
But it turns out there's also a mixed
strategy equilibrium. So here what we'd
like to do is find
a mixed strategy Nash equilibrium of
this game.
Now of course
we could say the pure strategy Nash
equilibrium we already found are
technically mixed strategy Nash
equilibrium where people's mixing
probabilities are just one and zero, but
what I mean is something that's actually
mixed, right? Um so what I really mean
is a mixed strategy Nash equilibrium
that's not a pure strategy Nash
equilibrium.
Um
Okay.
Well I think the first step is let's
just write some notations. So we're
going to look for an equilibrium. We're
going to look for some mixing. So let's
look for an equilibrium of the form
well, player one is going to put say
probability P1 on C
and let's say player two is going to put
probability P2 on C.
So our goal is to find a Nash
equilibrium of the form player one plays
P1 times C
plus 1 minus P1
times R. So what this means is with
probability P1 player one goes to the
Celtics game
and with probability 1 minus P1 player
one goes to the Red Sox game
and then similarly for player two, but
we have potentially a different number
here.
Okay?
And we want to find an equilibrium of
this form where maybe what we'd like is
we want it to actually involve mixing.
So let's say P1
0 is less than P1 is less than 1 and 0
is less than P2 is less than 1. This is
what we want. We want something where
each player is actually mixing. They're
not just playing one strategy with
probability one.
So I guess the trick is to think well,
what must be true here? So if we want
this to be
a mixed strategy Nash equilibrium
it must be that player one is willing to
mix between C and R given the way that
player two is playing. And based on what
we said before, what does that mean?
What must be true if player one is
willing to mix between C and R?
Yeah? Player one has to feel like
they're indifferent between C and R
given player two's strategy. Exactly.
And then the other direction
player two must also be indifferent
between C and R given player one's
strategy. So the way that we as the
analyst often solve for an equilibrium
like this is we look for mixing
probabilities that make the players
indifferent, right? So let's let's look
at this. There's two steps.
So
the mixture P1
must make
player two indifferent.
And this is a key point. You might think
I made a typo here, but but I didn't
actually, right? It turns out that the
probability with which player one mixes
is what determines whether player two is
indifferent.
Because player one's mixing
probabilities in equilibrium determine
the beliefs that player two has.
So whether player two wants to play C or
R
depends on their beliefs about player
one.
And the and the frequency with which
player one plays C or R. So it's
actually player one's mixing probability
that is responsible for determining
whether player two is indifferent. And
conversely, it's player two's mixing
probability that determines whether
player one is indifferent.
So when you set up when you try to solve
for these equilibrium
you know, it all looks nice. We have two
indifference conditions and two numbers
to solve for. Mathematically, it's
pretty easy, but the thing to remember
is that player two's indifference
condition is actually uh in this case
going to be determined by P1 and player
one's is going to be determined by P2.
So player two's indifferent condition,
we need to make sure that player two
gets the same payoff from C as from R.
So let's look at player two.
If player two plays C
well, they get a payoff of one
if player one plays C
and a payoff of zero if player one plays
R.
So what is their expected payoff?
Their expected payoff from playing C
is going to be P1
times one
plus 1 minus P1 times zero.
But the zero disappears and we just get
P1 in the left hand side.
So here P1 is
the
utility, the expected utility for player
two from playing C. So maybe I'll put a
C here and an R here
just to keep keep in keep track of what
we're comparing.
And this makes sense, right?
If I'm player two and I go to the
Celtics game
I know that if my opponent goes to the
Red Sox game, I get a payoff of zero.
So my only utility comes from if they
also go to the Celtics game. That
happens with probability P1 and if it
does happen, I get a payoff of one
because I like the Red Sox more. I only
get a payoff of one from the Celtics.
What about the other case? If we do if
we have the R, if I play R, what is my
payoff going to be?
Yeah? 1 - P1 times
Exactly, right?
So here, again, I get no payoff if they
go the other way.
1 minus P1 is the probability that my
friend also goes to the Red Sox game,
but now there's a two here because I
really like the Red Sox. So if they go
to the Red Sox game with me, I get a
payoff of two rather than one.
And now let's do the same thing for
player one. I'm player one. If I play C
given that my opponent is playing C with
probability P2, what is my payoff going
to be as player one?
Well, it's going to be two.
I get two with probability P2
and zero with probability 1 minus P2, so
I just get 2 P2.
And then if I play R
again, zero with probability P2, one
with probability 1 minus P2
so I get 1 minus P2.
And we can just do some algebra here.
And if we pull this over, we're going to
get P2
equals 1/3.
And then we get P1 equals 2/3.
So I want to caution here against I
think a common misinterpretation of
this.
Um
what a lot of people say is they say,
"Okay, this makes sense.
Player one goes to the Celtics game more
often.
Right? P1 is 2/3, more than half.
Because player one likes the Celtics.
And player two goes to the Red Sox game
more.
Player two goes to the Celtics game only
with probability 1/3, which means they
go to the Red Sox game with probability
2/3, because player two likes the Red
Sox more.
Is that right? What's
Do you see a problem with that
reasoning? I don't know. What do you
think? Does that seem right to you?
So, it turns out that the reason, if we
really look through the equilibrium,
the reason that player one
goes to the Celtics a lot is not because
they like the Celtics more,
but because their opponent likes the
Celtics less.
Right? Player one's mixing probabilities
have to make player two indifferent.
And because player two doesn't like the
Celtics very much, they're only willing
to go to the Celtics game
if they believe that player one is very
often going to the Celtics game.
And let's do the the reverse reasoning.
Why does player two go to the Red Sox
game a lot? It's true that player two
likes the Red Sox a lot. But the real
reason for this equilibrium is that they
have to go to the Red Sox game a lot to
make player one willing to go to the Red
Sox game.
Because player one prefers the Celtics.
They're only going to go to the Red Sox
game if they think it's more likely than
not that player two goes to the Red Sox
game.
So,
uh I think that's just a a key point
here about what's driving
the structure of this
equilibrium.
And I think that should make you wonder
a bit
because
I shouldn't care about making my
opponent indifferent. Right? So, I think
an issue, maybe a
a question,
is
if I'm player one here,
I'm given the way my opponent is
playing, I'm indifferent between C and
R.
So, why should I mix with exactly the
right probability that makes my opponent
indifferent?
It doesn't really seem like if I'm
indifferent, I mean, why go through the
the difficulty of doing all the
randomization? And I think that's the
question we'll just leave for now. We'll
talk a bit more throughout the course
about this, but I think it's something
to keep in mind that it's true I'm
willing to mix, but why do I actually
mix?
Uh
we do see it in practice.
Um I don't know. I I will open it up.
Are there any thoughts? I mean,
why do you Why do you think like poker
players actually do mix? They're
indifferent. They should be indifferent
if everyone else is mixing just right.
Why Why do they mix?
Why would you mix if you took penalties?
What would go wrong if you didn't mix?
So, yeah. Like they would know what you
were going to do.
And [snorts] then they would update
their strategy based on that. Right. So,
often the story we tell about mixed
strategies is often really a story about
a dynamic process where the game is
repeated. And for this reason we might
think that a mixed strategy Nash
equilibrium is a more compelling
prediction if the game is repeated over
time.
You don't want to have a reputation as
someone who always shoots left. Because
then your opponents would update on
that.
Now, then we have to really think about
well, what does it mean to develop a
reputation for something? And that's
takes us down a whole new path that
people have tried to formalize and think
through. Um it's not clear exactly what
it means.
Um
So, that's that's one story.
Um I guess another story I would say is
sometimes mixing is not literal mixing,
but what mixing means is you're making a
decision based on something that the
other person
isn't aware of.
So, it may be that, you know,
uh
let's take, I don't know, how someone
dresses. You may think, oh, it's someone
just randomizes the way they dress. But
really, they wear certain colors on
certain weather because that makes them
feel happy. But to you, not knowing
their careful algorithm for how they
choose their clothes as a function of
the weather, it just appears random to
you. Or similarly, maybe a penalty
kicker, when they come to the spot, sort
of feels a direction. One of their feet
feels a little different. They just feel
a direction to go to, and then they make
a deterministic choice about which
direction to shoot. But because you as
the opponent can't see that signal that
they're basing their shot on, it appears
random to you. So, sometimes we
literally observe randomization, and
sometimes behaviors appear random
because they're based upon things that
we can't actually observe.
So, just uh just one thing to keep in
mind.
And I think that's um
Good. Let me finish with
maybe one last
two last things.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, notice that in the game that we
looked at here,
uh
this game did not have a pure strategy
Nash equilibrium.
But when we moved to mixed strategy Nash
equilibrium, it did have a mixed
strategy Nash equilibrium.
And the question is, could we come up
with some really weird game where
there's no equilibrium? That maybe
wouldn't be so very very good for our
theory, because then we wouldn't have a
prediction about how people play. And
fortunately, it turns out, and this is
really Nash's key result in 1948, that
that's never going to happen.
Every game
within reason has a mixed strategy Nash
equilibrium. And let me say it so more
precisely, let me say every finite
strategic form game
I'll be a little more precise. I'll say
has at least one.
So, at least one. It might have only
one. It might have two. It might have
three. It may have infinitely many, but
it has at least one.
And when I say mixed strategy, that
includes pure strategy as a special
case. Right? So, I I might say mixed or
pure, but remember, we're going to think
of a pure strategy Nash equilibrium as a
special case
of a mixed strategy Nash equilibrium
where the players mix with degenerate
probabilities.
Uh now, this is not something we're
going to prove in the course.
This is actually quite a deep result.
So, I remember a a couple weeks ago,
last week, we talked about this
dominance best response duality, and I
also didn't prove that. That is somewhat
deep. This is much deeper. So, this is
maybe the mathematically deepest result
um in the course, and it uses something
called a fixed point theorem.
Uh and if you want to Google it, it's
either sometimes attributed to Brouwer
or Kakutani.
And these are actually
quite deep mathematical results. So, the
one of the mathematical results was
actually proven, I think, in 40 1944,
and then Nash proved this result in
1948. So, it's really using kind of
cutting edge math to to prove this new
result. Maybe not so cutting edge
anymore in 1944, but at the time, uh the
gap between sort of the math frontier
and the econ frontier was actually very
very close.
Um if you want to see the the proof,
you can uh look in the lecture notes.
The lecture notes give a proof
building upon these theorems. Uh the
real real depth is proving these
theorems, which we're not going to talk
about. I mean, we're not going to talk
about this proof either. Um but just
want you to keep that in mind. And uh
before we go, we have like three more
minutes. So, let me just conclude with a
few interpretations of Nash equilibrium.
I think
we talk about Nash equilibrium as kind
of the crowning achievement of game
theory, but over the last, you know, 70
years, people have always been searching
for justifications of Nash equilibrium.
And I would actually argue that Nash
equilibrium does not have as compelling
of a justification as, say,
rationalizability does. Of course, it
makes stronger assumptions, and it gets
sharper predictions. But whether we
actually find it compelling, I think is
not totally obvious. Again, on exams, if
I ask you to solve for Nash equilibrium,
you have to solve for it. You can't just
say, I don't believe in Nash
equilibrium. But I do think it's it's
helpful to to think about how compelling
this is. So, I want to present a few
interpretations of this.
So, one interpretation is about a stable
convention.
So, the idea of Nash equilibrium, it's
really about stability. It's that given
the way people are behaving, no one
wants to deviate.
So, a great, I think, example of this is
the the side of the road that we drive
on.
Why do we all drive on the right in the
US and drive on the left in England?
Right? You might say, oh, you get a
ticket if you drove on the on the left.
But that's not really the reason, right?
It's really cuz you're afraid you'd get
hit by a car. So, if everyone drives on
the right, it's best for you to drive on
the right. If everyone drives on the
left, it's best for you to drive on the
left. These are both stable conventions.
Um and we don't really need to ticket
people for driving on the wrong side of
the road. I mean, we do, but that's not
really what motivates them, I think, to
drive on the correct side of the road.
Um another is you can think of it as a
self-enforcing agreement.
Again, self-enforcing because no one
wants to unilaterally deviate from the
agreement. And I think this explains the
success of a lot of multilateral
international agreements. When countries
sign treaties, there's no court that can
adjudicate a treaty between countries,
or generally there's not.
So, why Why do people follow the treaty?
Well, often when treaties are set up in
the right way, people don't have an
incentive to unilaterally deviate. And
even though there's not some court that
would throw a country in prison, um they
often are still motivated to follow
these agreements. Uh and then another
interpretation is as a steady state.
And this kind of gets to our discussion
of penalty kicks. If you were to always
shoot right, the goalies would start
always guessing that you're going to
shoot right. So, then you might start
shooting left, and then over time we
think that you might converge to this
steady state.
Whether there's actually a a dynamic dy-
you know, a a real justification for
dynamics converging is actually a bit
more subtle, but the point is, if you
are in a Nash equilibrium, it's steady,
and there's no reason to move away from
that. And that's kind of the final
interpretation, and I'll leave it there.
So, I'll see you all next week.